The reasons US cars are so rare in Japan, which is the world's third-largest car market,...
...have more to do with Japanese consumer tastes,...
...the abiding if outdated stereotypes the Japanese have about the quality of American cars,...
...and the very different way customers shop for vehicles in Japan.
It is first important to note that Japanese brands all but completely dominate local roads.
More than 95 percent of all cars sold in the country are Japanese.
Imports make up the balance and most of those are higher-end European luxury vehicles and sports cars.
This is partly because the Japanese have pretty specific needs.
For one thing, space is incredibly tight.
Wildly popular in Japan are these so-called kei cars,...
...which are tiny vehicles preferred by drivers...
...who have to thread their way through narrow streets and crowded cities.
Kei cars alone make up 40 percent of the Japanese market and US automakers don't make them.